dernier gadget en date sur you motivé la
speakerine chat outils simples la web tv
canal i ching kuo ching quoi il filme
que tu verras ils fine que tu veux dire
beaucoup ça sert elle à la mort de
loctudy cristal est viscéral à la
maladière tour qui conclut de notre
programme à la waho mopti vous on a
serré tout petit mois jeanne jeune c'est
votre vrai prénom
oui je vois dans une revue de télévision
que vous êtes le spécialiste française
de lentilles présentation se veut dire
quoi lentilles présentation lentilles
présentation ça veut dire que j'ai rien
du tout d'une présentatrice c'est à dire
que je me goure toujours enfin je me
trompe toujours dans les programmes je
me trompe toujours dans le titre dans le
titre du film enfin j'ai rien du tout
d'une présentatrice et puis après je
fais toujours mais mes grimaces et tous
alors qu'une présentatrice normalement
elle doit être très sérieuses ont
travaillé ici parce que cette française
non non pas du tout